أكد البنتاغون في وقت متأخر من
ليلة الخميس أن الجيش الأمريكي نفذ
ضربة قتلت الجنرال قاسم
سليماني قائد
الحرس الثوري الإيراني ، وهي
منظمة ألقت الولايات المتحدة باللوم عليها
في مقتل عدة أشخاص في العراق
وزيادة عدد الهجمات ضد
الولايات المتحدة.  في الأسابيع والأشهر الأخيرة ، نفذ الجيش الأمريكي
هذه الضربة في
مطار بغداد الدولي ، وتم
تدمير مركبتين في الضربة بحسب
الجيش العراقي الأمريكي.  قائلاً إن سليماني
كان مستهدفًا على حد سواء لأنه كان متقدمًا
على منظمة إرهابية أجنبية مصنفة من قبل الولايات المتحدة
ولكن أيضًا لأنه كان
يخطط بنشاط لهجمات ضد
أفراد أمريكيين في المنطقة وكان
وراء هجوم صاروخي مؤخرًا من قبل
جماعة تعمل بالوكالة إيرانية أسفرت عن مقتل
مقاول أمريكي و
المظاهرات الأخيرة التي حاولت اختراق
المحيط الخارجي
للسفارة الأمريكية في بغداد
لنا  وصف الجيش هذا الأمر بأنه
عمل دفاعي تحدث وزير الدفاع
مارك إسبر إلى المراسلين قبل
أنباء الضربة وأخبرهم أن
اللعبة قد تغيرت فيما يتعلق بإيران
ووكلائها وأن الولايات المتحدة
ستتصرف بشكل استباقي للدفاع عن
أرواح ومصالح الأمريكيين  في المنطقة ، هذه
الضربة مثال كبير على ذلك ،
وقد أمر الرئيس ترامب بالفعل بإرسال
قوات عسكرية أمريكية إضافية إلى
المنطقة في أعقاب الأحداث
التي شملت السفارة والهجمات الصاروخية ،
وتم إرسال حوالي 100 من مشاة البحرية
إلى السفارة مئات من
المظليين الآخرين.  تم نشرهم في الكويت
للرد في حالة حدوث أزمة ، لذلك
يمكن استدعاء تلك القوات إذا
تصاعد هذا الوضع يعتقد الكثيرون أن
إيران سترد على الأرجح على هذا
الإجراء نظرًا لمكانة الجنرال سليماني
داخل الجيش الإيراني ، لكن الجميع
سيراقب ما سيحدث بعد ذلك في  هذه
المنطقة ولكن هذا ولكن
خطورة الوضع وهذا التطور
لا يمكن التقليل من ريا  ن براون
البنتاغون